President Biden likes to portray himself
as the uniter in Chief but he's catching
a lot of flack over a very divisive
commencement speech Biden was addressing
the graduating class at a historically
black college Howard University and
focusing a lot on race
we know that American history has not
always been a fairy tale
a harsh reality but racism has long torn
us apart
it's a battle
it's never really over enough of us have
the guts and the hearts
stand up
for the best in US
to choose love over hate
Unity over distributed progress over
retreat
stand up against the poison
of white supremacists I did my inaugural
address to a single out as the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy
wow all right um I'll start with you
Martha you know Biden's approval rating
right now among blacks is at 52 when he
first took office I believe he was at 82
so I suspect this race-baiting nonsense
that he's promoting is not doing him as
service I think you're right I mean I
think that there's been
um movement in the black vote uh over
the last several presidential elections
I think that you know I I think that
most people in this country want to be
treated in the words of President Obama
as not a Black America or a white
America but the United States of America
and it would be really nice to hear the
president who ran on a platform of
uniting the country really focus on that
that we have much more in common than
what divides us right I mean wouldn't
that be I honestly I think his poll
numbers would go shooting higher if he
took that kind of perspective and
encourage those individuals who were
having that graduation ceremony I
commend all of them to embrace that in
their lives as they move forward and you
know
urge Excellence for everybody
you know Jesse Biden didn't talk like
this in the 80s the 90s and the 2000s in
fact he was just the opposite why all of
a sudden is white supremacy the biggest
threat when race relations have improved
yeah he used to talk at clan members
funerals from what I remember now
they're going to keep trying to divide
us this is a very good school if you
graduate from Howard University you are
going places you are going to be working
for white people and why people are
going to be working for you so to have
the president come there and feed them
this stuff like they're victims of white
supremacy is such a disappointment and
you know what the biggest domestic
threat is two young black men in this
country other young black men with guns
and that's the truth and if you just
talk raw numbers you got health issues
to worry about coronavirus killed a
million people you got absent fathers
education issues
maybe there's a mass shooter who's a
white supremacist a couple times a year
but in terms of the biggest threat to
these very very intelligent black people
that have the world at their fingertips
this is not something I would be
drilling into their heads and this is
something that proves that white
supremacy is not what people think it is
they rank all of the ethnicities on
income in this country Indian Americans
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
on average Filipino Americans Japanese
Americans Chinese Americans all make
more money on average than white
Americans Hispanic Americans make more
money on average than African Americans
and it's all based on education it's not
white supremacy that's the determining
factor it's education you know Jessica
it I think it's borderline abusive the
way Biden promotes this in the schools
so that young white kids are made to
feel that you know any positivity that
they have for themselves is really the
result Cult of white supremacy it's
really the result of there being
privileged it's almost taking away the
The Pride that they can have in
themselves
so first of all I don't think that
there's anything that President Biden
could say that you guys would
particularly like I've never heard you
pay him in an oratorical compliment or
said that he really struck the right
tone something is always wrong and this
is consistently what he talks about and
it's rooted in truth so both attorney
general Merrick Garland and secretary
mayorkas have talked about that the
greatest threat to America comes from
domestic terrorists that are motivated
by racial supremacy of white people
that's just the facts about who is
killing you say it's a shooting every
once in a while where what 10 days past
the Allen Texas outlet mall shooting
right where the guy at swastikas on him
that goes in there and takes off little
kids faces we have manifestos of people
who go into Walmarts and say that you
want to get rid of brown people and it
is a serious threat and he's trying to
draw a distinction between how his
administration and how he sees the world
versus a previous administration what
could be a new Administration coming in
who who doesn't seem to be bothered by
it at all and there are tremendous
amount of achievements that the bind
Administration has done in improving the
lives of black people in America the
lowest black employment rate right now
the investments in hbcus like Howard
University stuff they're going through
the infrastructure Bill and that's what
he's trying to do and that ABC
Washington Post poll is a complete
outlier in terms of support and first of
all Trump beating Biden but in terms of
black support Latino support et cetera
so we'll see where that goes but that
number is off ABC's poll is not accurate
you don't think it's consistent I think
if there is a
there was a poll that came out the next
day that showed the exact opposite
findings they were 30 points off
Greg you want to wrap this up yeah I
just think it's time that white people
stop lying to black people right why do
why do we lie to them why do we tell
them hey when you get out into the real
world this is what you're going to face
that's a lie it's an outright lie white
supremacy is not a threat to them if you
look at the ADL who are very biased
towards labeling everything a racist act
they found 25 uh murders I guess in 2022
attributed to extremism out of 26 000
homicides
25 murders two Mass troops two mass
shootings so it's rare it's ugly it's
rare but it sure as hell ain't the
number one threat that is a bra the most
obvious lie you could come up with so he
is lying you have to ask why do you lie
to black people why do you lie to black
people why do liberals feel that they
have to do that because they need to
keep blacks angry they need to keep
blacks close to them right this does not
serve black people doesn't if it doesn't
serve black people it doesn't serve
white people either because it creates
conflict the people who need to cleave
blacks from whites do so because they
realize there is profit and discontent
they're rent seeking as long as there's
a problem whether it's racism or whether
it's homelessness a billion dollars went
to homelessness we don't know where it
went because you need a persistent
crisis in order to keep your job
consultants and corporations right
activists you got to keep this lie going
and once blacks walk away from this lie
oh they're going to be happy but they're
going to be pissed and I'm so gonna be
there for that
amen up next well this is Rich socialist
Bernie Sanders cashing in on his book
that bashes capitalism I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now